with the ever-expanding narrative of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe comes the
burden of mystery there are many
unanswered questions about the MCU some
of which have simmered on the backburner
since almost the very beginning here are
a few of the biggest lingering questions
both Ant Man films offer some the
lightest most comedy centered fare in
the MCU so it would be understandable if
the kinds of fans who always have their
ears and eyes open for potential secrets
let their guard down and missed a couple
of things but with the release of Ant
Man and the wasp one of the biggest
unanswered questions of the MCU may have
something to do with who the new Big Bad
of the MCU will be after Thanos is
finally defeated early in the film both
wasp and ghosts easily dispatched the
thugs of the ruthless sunny perch yet
birch just keeps coming back because
he's working for someone who doesn't
take no for an answer really this guy
again in case you were too busy laughing
and didn't notice
birch never reveals exactly who it is
he's working for he mentions his
employer to wasp and we hear him talking
on the phone with them but we never get
a name obviously it's too early to tell
it may be that director Peyton Reed was
simply setting up the villain for the
third ant-man pill but considering the
possibilities of Hank pimp's quantum
technology whoever's hunting for it
probably isn't looking to rob banks or
knocked over drugstores a heavy hitter
is coming for Pimm's Tech and they might
occupy Thanos his empty chief villain
throne after Avengers 4 in Avengers
infinity war we learned that Thanos
captured the first of the Infinity
stones off-camera the Power Stone also
known as the orb we see Nova prime put
the orbit of all tones and are in the
last few minutes of guardians of the
galaxy the mad Titan already has the
stone when he and the Black Order
attacked the Asgardian refugee ship and
infinity warp and later in the film we
learned that Thanos decimated zan dark
but the word decimate isn't always used
with precision particularly not when it
comes to Thanos we know his usual way of
doing things is to wipe out half the
population of a planet if half the
population of Earth were wiped out you
could use the word decimate without
sounding too traumatic so did Thanos and
the Black Order literally destroy the
whole population or did they just bring
it to its knees it's possible we might
see Nova prime or Corman day again
whatever happens it would seem strange
not to have the events on sand our
trigger more events further down the
road it may even be the narrative tool
Marvel Studios uses to bring the hero
nova into the MCU SIF was not only
missing from Avengers infinity war but
she was out of action for four Ragnarok
as well
according to actress Jamie Alexander she
didn't show up for the third Thor
because of a scheduling conflict with
her NBC action series blind spot Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige gave a
narrative explanation that leaves the
door open for sips returned saying Loki
would want Thor's closest allies far
away from him
just as we find out from scourge in the
beginning of Ragnarok that Heimdall was
falsely accused of treason
Loki probably also used his odin
disguise to get rid of sip Feige went so
far as to speculate that the god of
mischief had her vanished
if sip wasn't on Asgard when Surtur
destroyed it at the end of Ragnarok then
she wasn't on the refugee ship either
that means sip could still be alive out
there in the cosmos waiting to hear back
from a world that's long gone and a
people who aren't doing much better
strangely a term we haven't heard used
at all in the MCU yet is elders of the
universe in spite of the fact that three
of the elders from the comics have
appeared in the films
one of the elders for Marvel Comics ego
the Living Planet was a major villain in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 in the
comics the elders are a group of
powerful cosmic beings who share three
common traits each is powerful each is
the last surviving member of their
respective race and each is obsessed
with a specific pursuit for some it's
collecting for others its gaming
gardening or in some cases just good
old-fashioned killing though neither the
collector nor the Grandmaster have been
shown to have any overt relationship to
one another in the films in the comics
they're both counted among the elders
physically they both been given similar
marks on their chins it may be that
they're both meant to be related to one
another in some way but that's just a
footnote for the fans not something that
will ever matter that much in the
overall story of the MCU but there are
reasons to think the two could be much
more connected than you think both
potentially have some kind of
relationship with Loki remember that it
was Loki disguised this Odin who sent
Volstagg and SIF to deliver the ether to
the collector in the mid credit scene of
Thor the dark world and in Thor Ragnarok
we never learned exactly how Loki won
grandmasters favor
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 gave us
the answer to the origin of Peter quill
we learned who his father was and how
that lineage allowed quill to hold an
infinity stone without dying it was good
to get answers about Peter
but there's another Guardian who
origins remain shrouded in mystery we
know very little about rockets we know
he's the product of scientific
experiments we know the Nova Corps
referred to him as subject 8 9 P 1 3 who
calls itself rocket in the first
guardians film and of course we now
rocket isn't exactly thrilled about the
nature of his existence we don't know
the identities of the scientists who
made him why they did what they did or
how rocket escaped them Guardians writer
and director James Gunn has said he
doesn't plan to stick to Rockets comic
book origin but even with that in mind
we still don't know exactly what
direction is going with the story the
second and final season of Netflix's
iron fist ends with a tease Danny Rand
and Ward Meacham our globe-trotting
together to find a man named Orson
Randall in the comics Orson is an iron
fist who turned his back on his duties
to protect the sacred city of Kunlun the
Netflix series ends with the reveal that
Danny Rand acquired Randall's pistols
which appear to be infused with iron
fist energy though Randall's pistols
don't exactly have special abilities in
the comics the scene is a clear
reference to those stories unfortunately
we may never know what happens to Danny
in October 2018 iron fist became the
first of the Netflix Marvel series to
get the axe
Danny rands travels are briefly
mentioned in the final season of Jessica
Jones but not in a way that provides
closure or any details
perhaps Disney could revive to show some
day but if they do it won't be for a
while
Avengers endgame brought the Gamora from
2014 into the present filling star-lord
with the hope that he could have the
love of his life back in spite of her
untimely death during infinity war
unfortunately this Gamora has never met
quill and their first meeting doesn't
exactly go well she's nowhere in sight
after the battle with Thanos and his
armies leading some to wonder if Tony
Stark's nap unintentionally killed her
along with her adoptive father we know
now that a scene was filmed with Gamora
after the battle showing she did survive
Tony snap but it was deleted so where is
Gamora and what are her plans
shortly after end games released we made
some educated guesses but it's still
just speculation at this point we can
only guess that guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 will be the film that finally shed
some light on what happened to her where
is Gamora yeah oh do you one better
who's Gamora I'll do you one better
why is Gamora the fact that this is a
Gamora from the past also fills her
return with a lot of potential
this new old Gomorrah could go in any
direction she could rejoin the Guardians
she can become a villain or something in
between this is a gomorrah who never met
peter quill and who never fought
alongside him and the other guardians
who knows who she'll become in 2016's
Captain America Civil War Bucky Barnes
is treated as the most dangerous person
alive with enhanced abilities and skills
that make him a match for Captain
America a metal arm strong enough to
tear through Iron Man's armor and mental
conditioning that can turn him into a
killing machine Bucky is a potential
time bomb by the end of the film
T'Challa agrees to keep him in cryogenic
stasis and Wakanda
by the end of Black Panther we see Bucky
is unfrozen and living among two
challahs people which suggests he's made
quite a bit of progress strangely we
have yet to get confirmation that Cherie
was able to erase Bucky's mental
triggers when the paralyzed Everett Ross
is brought back to a condo for her help
in black panther assure he briefly
mentions helping another white boy but
that's it we've yet to hear any
definitive word on whether or not Bucky
can still be turned into a weapon with
that list of random phrases emo finds
it's civil war considering we know Zemo
is set to return in the Falcon in the
Winter Soldier miniseries it could be
that Sheree was never able to complete
her task Daniel Bruhl may even have
hinted this is the case when during the
2019 San Diego comic-con he posted a
first look of himself as Zemo from the
new series on Instagram in the caption
for the photo Bruhl added the ten phrase
passcode that turns Bucky back into the
Winter Soldier in Civil War Carol
Danvers ended up being pivotal in the
battle against Thanos she saves Tony
Stark destroys Stannis's ships sanctuary
before it can kill the other heroes and
in a one-on-one fight she proves to be
very capable against the man Titan in
spite of her importance she's gone for
most of Avengers endgame while
communicating with Black Widow be a
holographic image she lets her know not
to expect her for a while and then she's
gone until the final battle we probably
won't know until Captain Marvel - where
exactly the hero spent her time for most
event game but a good possibility is
that she was trying to stop everyone
else in the galaxy from killing one
another there are a lot of other planets
in the universe and unfortunately they
didn't have you guys what we get to see
how the snap impacts earth we have yet
to see how the rest of the galaxy
responds to losing half its population
it's possible if not likely that when it
comes to some of the interstellar
empires out there
the cosmos there are a lot of power
shifts in the wakeup thanasis snack
after all most of the galaxy has no way
of knowing in the immediate aftermath
why habits people simply disappear
confusion is probably raining all over
the spaceways after the conclusion of
infinity war and that's probably what
captain marvel is dealing with that said
we still don't know for sure the
aftermath of infinity war is so drastic
that one of the biggest changes in the
MCU and the years before that OSIS snap
seems utterly forgotten by the time of
avengers endgame there's no mention of
the world changing laws known as the
sokovia accords in either endgame or
spider-man far from home that means no
one has clarified whether or not
international law still requires the
Avengers to operate under the watch of
the United Nations after five years
Captain America is regularly visiting
the Avengers compound and attending a
support group so it doesn't seem like
he's a fugitive anymore ant-man's in the
quantum realm hawkeye's gone rogue and
the rest of Captain America's Civil
War's anti-registration heroes are
erased by Thanos to snap it seems clear
that after the end of infinity war
either the sokovia accords were repealed
or that no one was willing to enforce
them either possibility makes sense
after all Bruce Banner is allowed to
roam free and take selfies and diners
even though the last time he was on
earth he was wanted for destroying half
the city regardless we never learn
exactly why cap is allowed to roam free
or what the UN thinks about the Avengers
new talking raccoon and blue skinned
cyborg tan alert Ivonne also known as
the collector remains one of the most
mysterious figures in the MCU adding to
his mystery is the simple fact that we
have no idea whether or not he's alive
while we see the collector in infinity
war it isn't exactly him when we see fan
OHS torturing the collector for the
location of the reality stone it's an
illusion that Titan creates the pool the
Guardians the collector is long gone by
the time the Guardians arrive on
knowhere Thanos has already captured the
stone into bonds famous collection as a
blaze the annals might have killed the
collector before the guardians arrived
but it's also possible that the
obsessive tivan escaped and left the
reality stone behind without the stone
Timman meant nothing to the Titan so
perhaps the collector decided to ditch
the valuables and escaped with his life
we just don't know at this point we
don't get to see what happens to me only
or in the resolution of avengers endgame
Captain America has the hammer with him
or Hulk sends it back in time but it
isn't there with him when he reappears
as an elderly
presumably he would have returned the
hammer to Asgard circa 2013 along with
the ether that was clearly the intended
mission otherwise he would have left the
thor of that time hammerless when he
still had Malekith and the Dark Elf army
to deal with still what we don't see it
happen it's doubtful that Steve would be
selfish enough to keep me all near for
himself but it's possible something went
wrong did Steve find the thor of that
time and hand me only er to him or did
he just leave it standing on the ground
somewhere trusting that it would answer
Thor's call when needed
now that we know Jane Foster is coming
back for Thor love and thunder and that
she's somehow going to gain the power of
Thor the question of what happened to
the hammer seems more important it could
be that whatever method Steve chose to
return the hammer is what will lead to
foster becoming the MCU snoot god of
thunder
spider-man far from homes post-credit
scene has inspired a lot of fans
speculation about who we've been calling
Nick Fury the scene reveals that for at
least part of far from home if not
longer the real Nick Fury wasn't even on
earth
Talos the scroll replaced fury while
Sauron replaced Maria hill in the
meantime the real fury is shown on some
kind of space station or remote facility
with a bunch of other Scrolls the first
and most obvious question is how long
Talos and Sauron have been playing their
roles since the scrolls are introduced
in Captain Marvel which is set in the
90s it's possible Talos and Sauron have
been disguised this Burien hill for
multiple films
Talos could have been disguised as Fury
as early as 2015's Avengers age of
Ultron that's his first appearance after
Captain America the Winter Soldier and
it's doubtful that film's fury could
have been a scroll because Talos
probably wouldn't have been able to
retain his disguise after being nearly
killed by Bucky there's another burning
question - what exactly is fury working
on with the scrolls Talos and his
brother unlikely feel indebted to fury
after he helped save them from the creep
but that doesn't tell us what they're
doing with him speaking of the scrolls
we know have been hiding in plain sight
what about the ones we don't know about
fans have speculated for a long time
about which MCU characters could be
replaced by Scrolls and it turned out
that Nick Fury was officially one of
those characters but that spider-man far
from home post credit scene did more
than reveal that both fury and Maria
Hill were replaced by Scrolls it also
showed us that Scrolls have been working
with fury for a while and if that's the
case then what are the odds that this is
the only time here he's asked them to
use their shape-changing abilities for
his benefit they don't seem terribly
high
if that's the case then there are likely
more Scrolls out there on MCS earth
strategically placed than disguised as
regular humans if you saw spider-man far
from home then you know it give us the
return of a very minor character from
2018 Iron Man
William Ginter Riva a scientist working
for Stark Industries an Iron Man returns
in a very different way in the Spidey
sequel and far from home Quentin back
recruits Riva as part of a small army of
disgruntled Stark employees unlike Beck
Riva survives the events of the film and
apparently does more than survive an
amid credit scene we learned that an
altered video has been released which
seems to prove that Spider Man murdered
Quentin back but not before Beck could
reveal Spidey's true identity since
rebeaud was recording the events
remotely he's likely the person who fed
the doctored video to Jay jonah Jameson
if Riva is the one who sets up Spidey we
have to wonder why is Riva just trying
to get back at spider-man or does he
have something bigger planned it doesn't
come off as a guy with the stiffest
backbone in the MCU so it doesn't seem
likely he's gunning to be Mysterio
successor
maybe Riva didn't release the
information to the public maybe he sold
it to someone else we haven't met yet
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU were coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]